one instance that i think was probably
is still to this day one of the most
egregious was uh michael brown i mean
they still are saying hands up don't
shoot they are still pushing his
rhetoric and agenda and that to me has
stimulated all of this fear and hate and
misinformation
and where you can just blatantly lie
about the police and it's just
acceptable you could say that the black
man had his hands up and was executed in
the middle of the street and and that's
totally fine even though the doj and
with a black president or black attorney
general found that the officer did
nothing wrong
you still can push that and that leads
to uh the jacob blakes that leads to
you know all of these other cases
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former police officer and now author of
the new book beaten black and blue being
a black cop in an america under siege
brandon tatum my friend welcome back to
the reuben report
what's going on dave
i'm doing all right as i said to you
right before we started just trying to
survive the revolution
and you
oh doing the same thing you know we
we're both in this together and i'm sure
we're both uh trying to make a
conservative effort to do something
about what's going on and keep a
positive attitude so i think we're on
the same page man
indeed we are that very much about
keeping a positive attitude and kind of
knowing what you're saying all that that
is sort of what the book is about we'll
obviously get to that i know most of my
audience is familiar with you already
you've been on the show a couple times
but for those that aren't can we just do
a quick recap of the the bio of brandon
tatum what made you a guy that's writing
a book about policing and and doing
crazy youtube shows like this
yeah you know the funny thing is man i
grew up in fort worth texas uh a young
man with parents were divorced and all
that other stuff and you know some
people may think that i would have
fallen down a particular path but i
believe that god had a plan for me in
college i played football
i was leaning more left
i got saved in 2008 and i never in my
life thought about being a police
officer i knew i was going to play in
the nfl i did not get drafted in 2010
although i was in the draft and it
really changed my life i became a police
officer after doing the ride-along and
my political views changed my worldview
changed in a significant way and i was a
police officer for six and a half years
i did the swat team i was a field
training officer i was a spokesperson i
did almost everything that i could on
the police department and really during
the barack obama's era is where things
begin to really change significantly for
me and with the attacks on police during
that period of time and and the rhetoric
coming from the white house this book
idea came to my mind man i said you know
what i feel like i'm getting beat up
from both directions i'm getting beat up
as a black man trying to be a police
officer by the black community and then
i'm getting beaten up for wearing a
uniform in general by the population
that have been swindled by the
propaganda from from the mainstream
media and these political leaders and i
said one day i'm gonna write a book and
and uh i wrote the book last year and
leading into this year i made some
additions to it because of the george
floyd situation however it's going to be
published november 30th and i'm excited
about it so there's obviously a ton to
talk about there related to when things
changed with policing and how it changed
but you mentioned sort of getting it
from both sides and we've talked about
that a little bit before but can you
just go into that a bit more how going
into these black communities as a black
man in some ways you told me last time
it kind of helped at times because it
gave you a little cred but then in
another way it was sort of like you were
seen as like a traitor or something like
that
yeah 100 you know some things some
people there were reasonable rational
individuals
sometimes they felt the connection with
me because i look like them you know and
maybe i sound like them because i got a
kind of a country accent it kind of
going it's kind of going away now but at
the time you know i was a lot more
country and so people maybe identified
with me and i was able to communicate
with individuals that some officers
couldn't um
more so than not people would criticize
me because i'm black and and are you
working for the white man and you're a
traitor to your people
and you know even when they would spew
rhetoric because this the white man
system of systemic racism it's like look
i'm a part i'm a part of this system and
you are proclaiming that i'm a problem
and that i'm involved in systemic racism
and even just last week i was two weeks
ago i was at the revolt summit which is
a summit for primarily just black people
i think
a lot of celebrities there rick ross was
there
p diddy is there he runs the
organization and i was on the panel as a
black police officer and literally
everything i said to support the
relationship between law enforcement and
in the black community i got booed um so
that that sentiment
is the reason why i think you know kind
of drew me to writing this book and
wanting to express this is another side
of it that people may not understand is
that this is what it's like actually
being a black man in america on the
police department did i did i see a clip
of that from revolt did you post a clip
of that getting booed or am i thinking
i think i might be thinking of something
that was it was not that
they may have posted uh tater report may
have posted that i had attended there
but you know what the funny thing is
they scrapped when they posted this live
because it was pre-recorded they
scrapped everything me and that other
black officer said we said a lot of
profound things that i think could be
invaluable to the community and they
deleted it when they posted it which is
it's shameful
so what do you make of that i mean you
were invited it's not as if they don't
know what you think right like it's not
that you're gonna suddenly get there and
they're like holy cow this guy
uh you know doesn't fall in line with us
exactly they know that to begin with
what do you make of even being invited
and then were you able to get across any
of the ideas to some of the people that
maybe were booing you
nah i mean there were people there that
already agreed kind of with the
sentiment of the police officers that
were there all the black cops that were
there supporting the event um some
people already agreed but the others you
know they had their mind fixed and you
can see that it's a rigged situation
where you have uh you know them having
other voices to express the totality of
the black experience and then when it
when the push come to shove when the
audience is bigger than 50 people when
it's going out to the millions of people
that follow the revolt uh network they
completely silence your voice and the
crazy thing is is that they allow the
misrepresentation of police officers and
hateful divisive rhetoric or divisive
rhetoric they allow those uh panelists
to have a highlighted voice and then he
deleted everybody else that said
anything different so to me it speaks to
the bigger overarching issue that
there's a
uh
effort and a push in order to block any
uh thought that's different than the
mainstream idea they want to push right
so you mentioned okay the the way the
black community sometimes felt when
you'd go into these neighborhoods and
then you mentioned the other side that
you were getting it from both sides
you're sort of describing that already
but what was that like as a police
officer you're saying okay i'm going in
to do my job but now here's the people
on the outside who are also hitting you
for it
yeah and one thing that i learned before
i became a police officer that i had no
idea what police officers actually did
and then when i became a police officer
i was like oh my god man we do stuff
that people have no idea about i mean
we're put in situations the things that
we see the stress that we are under the
decisions that we have to make in a
split second when uh you know you take
it to trial and attorneys have months
years to deliberate and figure out a
strategy to argue your you know half a
second decision um but we would get
pushback you know with the george floyd
not the george floyd because i wasn't a
cop during that time but michael brown
and some of these other incidents people
just projected negativity on you you had
to be a murderous thug even though none
of that happened in the city of tucson
where i worked and it was it was hard
man it was very disheartening because i
knew the men and women who worked with
me and worked around the country
putting your life on the line for other
people i mean this is not a video game
man this is not oh it is you know like
like a pre-recording or something i mean
you mess up
it's real life this is this is real
real time and the men and women i knew
their families a lot of people just
great individuals who have a passion for
supporting their communities and to see
them get just ragged on
with false narratives being pushed was
something that was like you know what i
gotta write a book and i gotta tell the
story and correct some of this stuff
because people aren't getting a fair
evaluation of law enforcement so that's
exactly what you do in the book and you
mention many of the names that people
have heard and if you want to highlight
one particular story feel free but one
of the things that i find interesting
about this is there's a certain
obsession with the trials an obsession
with all the minutia of what happened
and i think what you said a moment ago
is right it's like you guys have to make
snap decisions it doesn't mean all the
decisions are right but then months
later you got lawyers and judges and
trial experts and everybody
looking at everything with a microscope
and it's like that's not exactly how it
all happens in real life
yeah i mean you got to think of this you
know some people have probably
experienced a dramatic situation where
they feel um a sprayed or a tense
situation where sometimes they feel like
they froze or they had tunnel vision or
they didn't know what was going on
they're shaking the adrenaline is
rushing you got to imagine
the police officers are experiencing
what you are experiencing but then have
to make a decision whether to kill
somebody or not or whether to you know
do different arrests or chase
in a split second and then after the
fact people running more than
quarterback and say you know i wouldn't
have done that you shouldn't have shot
that person but it's like the same fear
that you feel
from somebody knocking on your door whom
you don't know who it is you know which
is nowhere near the fear of a man
pulling a gun out on you or you think
he's putting a gun down on you um i just
wish that people could have a glimpse in
into policing where they could say okay
i understand i may not agree the cop may
be wrong but at least i'm coming from a
standpoint and saying i understand the
stress i understand what these officers
may go through there may be another side
of this that i may need to consider
before making a a formal conclusion so
the goal is not to convince or brainwash
anybody into anything but to say there's
another side of this that you may want
to be privy to so you can make an
educated opinion about things that go on
in law enforcement you talk about the
media a lot of the book obviously i mean
is that problem that you're laying out
right there is that purely on the media
or should the police departments be
doing something different should the you
know local the mayors the governors like
where does that really fall when when
you have that disconnect between what's
really going on and then what we see
i think there's blame to go around in
all aspects you know law enforcement you
know i would like to consider them to
hold themselves accountable as well and
that we need to work on our messaging we
need to work on being more involved in
the community we need to recruit
individuals from the community to be a
part of the police department so the
police department has an objective you
know the leaders
local government they have an objective
as well i mean they need to push and
promote and support the joining together
of the community and police and also
parents people who are in the community
it's not just the police officers you
need to raise your children in a way in
which you're not demonizing law
enforcement before they ever have an
interaction
why can't you go out as a community
leader and say look we want to be more
involved in the community we want to do
ride-alongs
everybody together should work in a
sense to to make sure that that
connection happens um it's i don't
believe it's just one side or the other
i think everybody has to come together
and then we can see a better more
equitable relationship between law
enforcement and the community right that
was equitable in a good sense not the
way that the word is usually used how
worried are you how worried are you that
um that basically what has happened now
in the democrat cities in the
progressive cities is they've demonized
the police to such a point and defunded
the police to such a point that not only
are you going to get less qualified
people but that the the breakdown is
just too severe sort of like in
minneapolis ilhan omer she defunded the
police and then when people saw a crime
spike and murder spike and everything
else what'd she do she blamed the police
for not doing their job because there
weren't enough of them i mean it's
extraordinary you got to kind of admire
the evil
yeah i mean these people are i think
that they are not acting in good faith
right i believe they push rhetoric that
they think could be trendy enough to get
them elected but it doesn't have real
life application and in many cases they
would love to see things get destroyed
so they can be the the the focus of
change you know it's like no you created
the problem now you want to be the
solution to the problem you know and i
think that that's where they're coming
from the citizens are experiencing this
i mean when you demoralize the police
because defunding the police happens in
a in a fiscal year right so if you talk
about defunding now you have to wait to
the next budget then to cut the budget
um so they may not
have the effects of the defunding until
the next fiscal year however when you
mention it you start to demoralize the
police department you start to create
rhetoric and in in the morale of the
police department begin to crumble
police begin to or they eliminate
proactive policing which is one of the
main key of policing to help the
community and to stop crime is being
proactive they stay they that
perspective of policing begins to go
away
good officers with training and
experience and leadership leave the
police department through retirement and
then you have young people coming up
with no guidance young people coming up
lost in the police department and then
if you don't pay them well the people
who are good and they'll get another job
then you're going to be stuck with
people who
may not not everybody but may not be as
qualified and then you have unqualified
police without proper training in in
finance so
i really wish that that people would
take a step back and look at it and say
what are the complaints of law
enforcement okay they need better
training okay we need more funding so
that we can train officers recruit
better officers that takes more money
not less money now you can reallocate
funds
um if you feel like there's wasteful
spending but to completely be mon you
know d i would say uh
defund i was gonna say devalue
demonetized but but defundable will be
demonetized we know that right right
i'm so used to that word demonetization
so you know to you know to defund the
police is
it's not it's not a winning strategy and
the crime rate has has spoken on their
behalf
do you see any hope in that regard that
as we've seen these cities defund i mean
seattle did a major defund push we got
chop crime went crazy murders i think
something like six up 600 percent but
now suddenly they're saying okay maybe
we're not going to fully defund or the
mayor of even crazy portland who you
know got heckled out of his own
apartment had to leave because of
protesters and move suddenly he's moving
a little against it do you see some hope
in some of these places
yeah i think that things ebb and flow
you know you're gonna have uh police
becoming excellent and then you're gonna
have times where they hate the police
and and i think that we're experiencing
that now because it's a mathematical
equation it's very simple there's no way
to evade it if you defund the police you
lose police officers then you cannot
have a adequate amount of people to to
push law and order and so people are
going to do crimes and here's here's
another thing
in addition to defunding the police and
demoralizing police when you have the
prosecutors
not even prosecuting people on crimes
especially in places like california and
different places where you can steal 900
worth of stuff and you're not going to
be prosecuted when you couple that with
defunding the police i mean you a city
cannot exist a city cannot stand small
businesses cannot live even major
corporations have the financial support
to leave a city and then you have an
economic structure that's that's you
know downtrodden or destroyed in some of
these cities where you see the
proliferation of violence and
proliferation of theft i mean we see it
all over the country now people are just
bomb rushing these places stealing
hundreds of thousands of millions of
dollars worth of property
it can only go on so long before people
begin to say okay enough is enough
there's no way we can survive this you
know keep people dying every day in the
streets i i come outside i used to be
able to have my car to park it on the
street now it's getting vandalized
people taking my my property i don't
feel safe
when when that begins to happen you see
the character of people voting you see
that beginning to change
i went out to dinner in san francisco
with our friend candace owens we went to
a nice steak joint morton's steakhouse
on a nice street in san francisco a
couple years ago our car got broken into
they stole my bag with my notebooks and
my clothes and my nintendo wii
the whole thing and uh and i took
pictures of the broken glass outside the
restaurant and i said hey my car just
got broke into or the car we were we
were that was driving around just got
broke into while we were in san
francisco and i had i kid you not
thousands of responses basically saying
what kind of idiot leaves a bag in a car
on the street in san francisco that's
how bad it's gotten
yeah that's troubling man i mean i i
don't know if we're getting desensitized
um to crime but it's like in a normal
sense maybe even before you know
a decade a couple decades ago this
probably wouldn't have been as prevalent
like you should be able
to believe that people aren't going to
take your property that belongs to you
it's just we don't live in a society
where you can just break the law just
because you feel like it and if you do
break the law that should be
accountability and now
people expect you to say oh you can't
leave yourself in the car even though it
belongs to you even though you lock your
car you can't leave it in there because
there's a somehow the burden is on you
to protect your property from people who
are a thieving and and i don't think
that's the way society is structured in
a way it should work the way that we
should look at society is that if it
don't belong to you you shouldn't put
your hands on it if you don't live there
you shouldn't be going into somebody
else's property it's that simple and if
you do
you got you have to be held accountable
and
that's in the in the cities where they
believe law order is important and they
fund their police and they support
investigations like that because i know
that people may think it's a small deal
man but
i bet you were hurt over losing this you
feel violated yeah you know and that's a
real feeling in the into and for cities
to defund the police and say oh that's
not a big deal no it's a big deal to you
that's going to affect your life and
your emotionally um so
i really wish they would change the way
they perceive uh criminal behavior and
us to start cracking down on it yeah and
it was more the way that so many people
were just saying the same thing like ah
what kind of idiot does that as if like
you just don't it's like we've all just
accepted the the horror that that is
going on up there um what kind of uh
pushback do you get from officers who
say well actually if we don't
prosecute some of these crimes maybe
that helps us because we're not
stretched as thin
some of these people they're either on
drugs or mentally ill like that's not
exactly what we should be doing like how
does that conversation go
well i believe most reasonable officers
don't disagree with me because
if we don't prosecute these people they
don't just disappear right if you're
smoking crack today you're gonna be
smoking crack tomorrow and if you break
it into buildings today you're gonna be
breaking in tomorrow uh most officers
would agree that we need to be stronger
on it and the prosecutors need to
prosecute people and actually take them
to jail for the things that they do um
just like we saw in wisconsin you know
you got the guy running over people he
had just made a cash bale of like a
thousand dollars and he's a convicted
felon he he is a dangerous criminal he
should have never been on the streets
and so when you do things like bill
reform and all this crazy stuff that
they do
this person is the next crime
this person is the next suspect in a
violent murder and so law enforcement
officers and and i don't get much
pushback from it but those who may want
to push back it's like use your common
sense like we do need to hold these
people accountable just because if
marijuana is legal that does not mean
that people aren't gonna the crime
that's associated with marijuana uses
the sales the production the shipping
even the illegal marijuana that's not
gonna stop because it's legal um you can
make
heroin legal that's not gonna stop
people from the effects of heroin the
criminal element of heroin the violence
that come along with heroin heroin the
gun violence that's associated with
these things they're gonna still persist
it's not gonna stop just because uh a
law says it's legal or illegal yeah it's
funny because it's like i can make a lot
of good libertarian arguments on
legalizing and all sorts of stuff uh but
as i've discussed with michael malus
many times it's like you still don't
want the crack house next door whether
it's legal or illegal you know it comes
with a whole a whole bunch of stuff uh
so you do write about a bunch of the
names that we've all heard about over
these last couple years um but you know
before we get into that since you
mentioned what happened just now in
wisconsin uh and the cash bail that let
this guy out
what would you say is the most shocking
part of this i mean i talked about on
the show this morning how within two
three days of this thing happening it's
off the cnn front page they're just not
talking about it because it doesn't fit
the narrative i don't care about the
race of the perpetrator or the victims
they do right like they like race stuff
but this one didn't fit the equation for
them
right i mean it's shocking i mean it's
not shocking to me it's disappointing to
me that the media is just they're not
genuine i mean this guy is this is
almost as significant as a terrorist
attack i mean this these are two these
are two situations that we've seen the
media just blow under the rug you got
this one in wisconsin where a man is
involved in domestic violence i think he
ran his girlfriend leg over then he
plows through children
this is this is you know i don't know i
can't i don't want to say this and get
it wrong because i don't know what the
death toll of the boston bombing was but
you got to think a crowd of people
getting mowed down little kids are
getting mowed down people have died
people were dead on the scene of this
maniac and
this guy is a is a criminal
a profound criminal if this guy was
white
and ran down a group of black people
chanting in the middle of the street
uh
we would hear none stop we
we still hear about charlottesville it
was one guy who they determined was a
white supremacist he killed one person i
think he ran over maybe six people
killed one person they still talking
about that they're still saying this is
a systemic problem in our country racism
and the guy ran over and killed a white
person
a black person does it to all white
people with with racial undertones in my
opinion
and they have you can see the social
media posts i mean you're not you're not
making it up obviously yeah
it's there and then also
they go on and on about kyle
rittinghouse he's a white supremacist i
mean kyle rittinghouse is going to break
the record for the most lawsuit
victories possible because they all
disparaged him however he was he was not
guilty he always have been not guilty
he's not even close but they bash him in
the media the black kid in dallas texas
who went into the school i think was in
arlington technically he went into the
school he got into a fight he pulled a
gun out and shot
three or four people one the 17 year old
kid that he shot is in critical
condition
this kid got out the next day and threw
a party
his family came out and said that he was
bullied the black police chief came out
and said he wasn't bullied and i know
people in the community that told me
that he was selling drugs and what
happened is he met somebody out of their
money so he had to carry a gun around in
case they tried him and he ended up
getting into a fight and shooting people
this is a active school shooter
and he get out the next day yeah and
they don't even smile
yeah nobody's heard about it that big
smiling picture i mean it's just it's
pretty extraordinary um
on the on the written house one um the
meme out there seemed to be that this
guy is a white supremacist and if you
listen to half the media it was
basically
he shot three black people he did not
shoot any black people this was a white
kid
shot white people
in self-defense the whole thing was
screwed up how do we get past some of
this stuff i mean how do we
show people this is just not true
well hopefully the people who want to be
informed will watch the trial at least
watch highlights of the trial and come
up with their own conclusion about what
happens because when you listen to the
mainstream reader you will be deceived
right they make the picture of this guy
and even to this day you see black lives
matter out protesting it at the verdict
it's like dude this was a white guy who
they consider a suspect and then you
have white victims you have a white
judge you have a white prosecutor you
have a white defensive team
what are y'all even talking about this
has nothing to do with black people this
has nothing to do with black in general
and if you want to make the argument and
say uh this is a white supremacist uh a
picture of white supremacy and criminal
justice which white people the white
people that died they didn't get no i
mean if you feel like they were
unlawfully shot they didn't get any
justice it's just it's just foolery it's
a they made a mockery and the sad part
is that they're willing to
forego
the the rights of individuals the
constitutional rights of individuals
somebody's dignity martin luther king
died in an effort to help us understand
that we should all be treated equally
they are foregoing martin luther king
all of our ancestors all of the wars
that have fought just to push an agenda
in my opinion to sell advertisement and
fear this kid was never a white
supremacist and then they connected them
to the proud boys the vice president of
the proud boys who i think he went to
jail for burning the blm flat he's a
black man he's the vice president or
like the chair of proud boys i have
interacted with problems all the time
and i've interacted with black ones
hispanic ones i was in la and they came
to one of my events to help do security
um just just on their own and most of
them were hispanic
so it's like
it's a it's a it's a rhetoric that's
being pushed and i'm hoping that people
see the hypocrisy at minimum when he's
found not guilty at least go back and
say well
why he was found now guilty let me go do
some research instead of just blaming it
on the system so so going into some of
those other names obviously we don't
have to cover all them but because you
hit on some of the names that we've
heard a lot of over the last couple
years is there one particular one either
the trial or the events that unfolded
that you think was most egregious sort
of in the way police were treated or the
result of it or or whatever else
yeah i think i i think i mentioned a few
of them you know i kind of lumped a
couple of them together um one instance
that i think was probably
is still to this day one of the most
egregious was uh michael brown i mean
they still are saying hands up don't
shoot they are still pushing this
rhetoric and agenda and that to me has
stimulated all of this fear and hate and
misinformation
and where you can just blatantly lie
about the police and it's just
acceptable you could say that the black
man had his hands up and was executed in
the middle of the street and and that's
totally fine even though the doj and
with a black president or black attorney
general found that the officer did
nothing wrong
you still can push that and that leads
to uh the jacob blakes
that leads to
you know all of these other cases that i
take some of which i speak about in the
book that leads to brianna taylor where
you could just make up that she was
sleeping in her bed you can just make up
she was the emt and they hit the wrong
house when she was on the search warrant
she was involved in a criminal
enterprise and unfortunately her
boyfriend shot a cop at the door and
they returned fire and she ended up
dying subsequently but you can just make
up the fact that jacob blake was doing
nothing wrong when he had a knife in his
hand and he was actually uh trespassed
from the area he was area restricted
because he had sexually assaulted his
baby mama he shows up she calls the
police he has a knife they shoot him you
can just blatantly say that they shot
him for no reason macar bryan um they
had gone away because they they knew the
girl was trying to stab that other girl
when she got shot by the police you can
blatantly say they gunned down a 16 year
old girl with no unarmed
and the people sitting there at the
scene
saw that she had the knife and they go
on tv and say she was unarmed because in
our society today because of michael
brown you can just make up whatever you
want and you can cry over it i mean that
is crazy to me that one when we've all
seen the video she's got the knife she
could basically either stab the other
girl or or decapitate her in that moment
and people are going oh he should have
shot the leg or he should have shot or
he should have used a taser etc etc it's
like like i guess at some level that
sort of makes sense like you don't want
to kill somebody obviously you don't
want to legally shoot somebody on the
other hand
the person who's about to be killed they
need to be saved they that was to me
that one because it was just so obvious
to be angry at that police officer who's
trying to save someone's life woke up
that morning did not know he was gonna
have to save someone's life and and he's
a freaking big-ass knife
he's a hero i mean essentially he's a
hero i bet the parent of the girl that
was gonna get stabbed think i mean i i
don't know these days but you would
imagine that the parents think that he's
a hero i mean you gotta understand like
people have not been a police officer
the way he handled himself and the way
he was able to use force against only
that one person he hit nobody else he
used the amount of force necessary to
prevent her from killing the other girl
the guy was composed he did his dog-own
job um and it's a split-second decision
you got to think he sees a 16-year-old
girl but he also see another young lady
that needs her life saved and he did
what he had to do to make that happen
and lebron james come out and demonize
the man and it's like
listen dave this is a it's a bigger
problem than just misunderstanding like
there is an effort and ignorance within
a large population of our community the
black community and the community at
large of people just being dumb i mean
they don't do any research they don't
look at people still think
uh uh kyle ridden has killed black
people like some people still are saying
black lives matter he couldn't kill them
black people
even after to do andrew i think his name
was andrew coffey
he was he got off the same day as kyle
reading house on a self-defense case
when he killed a police officer in a
swat raid
i believe the verdict was i mean i i
accept the verdict i didn't watch the
trial so i don't know if the verdict was
right or not according to my opinion but
i i accept it but you gotta they if he
was black if kyle really house was black
this wouldn't happen well you got a
black man right here that killed a white
i don't know if the cop was white but he
killed a police officer this is prime
real estate for the racist justice
criminal justice system to throw a black
man under the bus and he gets off on a
self-defense charge and come on man like
you can't give them more evidence and
they just don't receive it
brandon i assure you that the pandemic
of dumb people has nothing to do with
anyone's skin color you know this is
this thing is across the system right
now absolutely across the system do you
sense that this is all ramping up again
it seems to me like you know we had all
the riots and the blm stuff and the
antifa stuff before the election then we
sort of got the results that the
mainstream wanted okay joe biden's
president we had 10 months of nothing
then in the last month it seems like the
race stuff is starting to bubble up
again we get the kyle rittenhouse
verdict we get what happened just now in
wisconsin it feels like it's about to
all start again almost as if and i think
this is sort of what you're saying it's
kind of manipulated this isn't all
organic bubbling up from the bottom
frustrated kids
yeah if you think about it these
occurrences of police getting into
shootings with people or shooting people
unarmed or whatever case to be this is
consistent every year there's nothing
new
funny thing is is when election time
comes around it's all of a sudden the
biggest thing that have ever happened to
us in world history i mean this is what
they make it out to be they did a mod
aubry's case
and kyle rittinghouse case almost
simultaneously and i think they did it
for a purpose because you had kyle
reading house which i think that they
wish that he was found not guilty and
they could have said look white
supremacy and then the mcmichaels where
they believed that they would be found
guilty which they did today um they were
going to say look white supremacy these
are two cases that they can compile
together to cause the world to have a
uproar for the next i don't know how
many months i mean they are just pushing
this and pushing it and pushing it and
with the with the pandemic and
everything else they are creating a
crescendo of of violence and and tension
amongst us because the biggest thing
isn't just the killing it's the racial
tension it's the fact that the president
of the united states claimed that kyle
rittinghouse pretty much i'm
paraphrasing that this is somewhat of an
injustice he just said that the
mcmichaels got convicted which i
disagree with the conviction but i
accept the verdict um that they got
convicted today and then we have a long
way to go in our society until we what
do you mean
in our society you should be able to
break into people's houses and do
whatever you want and
and not be held accountable to it in our
society i mean
they stoke these things because it makes
black people mad it makes white people
mad and they want us to hate each other
and if we keep hating each other they
come out during election season and say
look i'm going to be a part of the
change y'all creating the problem you as
part of the change nah not really
you just mentioned something interesting
which i agree with this idea that they
sort of wanted the result that they got
at the written house trial because if if
he had been convicted well then they
would have had to calm down for a little
bit that would be the natural
inclination like oh the system must work
i guess it isn't a white supremacist
system i guess i guess the patriarchy
isn't as scary
but that's not what they want they don't
want the pressure taken off right the
activists i'm talking about the base
they want the result that seems like the
bad result because that adds fuel to the
fire i mean that's a very dangerous
place to be in it with so that no matter
what happens
uh you're gonna be angry
yeah i mean they want it from both sides
i mean think about this for a minute
they when kyle reading houses his
verdict came out they are up the world
is in white supremacy is stronger than
ever they compared i think they compared
it to like emmett till i was like
y'all are just out of control and then
when the mcmichaels were found guilty
this is this this should have been
a time to say well this was the right
verdict in their opinion this is the
right verdict and we could no
this is a time to say finally they got
it right and we got so far to go it's
like you can't have it both ways you
can't say because the verdict wasn't in
my favor
the whole system is wrong white
supremacy is is worse than it's ever
been and then the verdict is in your
favor because they found the michaels
and all three of them guilty of all
eight charges or whatever they were
charged with um and they're gonna spend
the rest of their lives in prison and
now that the verdict is your way now all
of a sudden this is this is what justice
looks like it's like wait a minute man
is the criminal justice system racist
and systemically racist or is it not um
but they they they are mad when it is
they're mad when it isn't they just live
in a constant state
of of just hatred and turmoil and
revenge
so i know that uh that you and candace
and larry elder and thomas soul and many
other david webb many other black
conservatives you guys get hit from both
sides of course and you know get some of
the worst possible stuff said about you
that is you know really unimaginable at
this point from the so-called tolerant
people usually but what what do you make
of the people on the other side of this
and i hate to play the identity politics
game but like when you watch joy read or
you see the clips of joy read on msnbc
or you see michael eric dyson or al
sharpton or the usual suspects that are
racializing everything constantly saying
the most anti-racist or anti-white
racist stuff you can imagine
what do you is it just purely like it's
it's the grift it's just the grift with
these people do they believe it
what do you think
you know what i i it's hard to tell you
know michael eric dyson i you know what
i think that some of these individuals
they have built their whole life around
this
around this victim mentality and they
can't deviate because they've wrote
written books
they have made a name saying that i'm
fighting for justice piggybacking on
real people who are fighting for justice
like martin luther king
but they're piggybacking on these people
and that's their whole identity so they
can't they can't deviate from an
identity because they lose everything
and they are afraid they don't get
called to sell out uncle tom [ __ ]
because no matter how much you've been
doing work for black people in the
community you do one thing that that
they don't agree with you you ain't
never been black and so i wonder i often
wonder you know uh they think the same
thing about us which is very interesting
to me and i tell people this i say they
think we crazy we think they're crazy
how do you determine who's right or
wrong look at facts
there is no factual basis that there's
systemic racism in our country there are
racist people duh there's going to be
racist people till we all die i mean to
jesus come back to earth uh even if it's
a thousand years from now there are
going to be people who hate other people
for whatever reason when you go to all
white community white people mad at
other white people for whatever reasons
you know what i'm saying and you go to a
black community you too light-skinned
you too dark-skinned and you po you
think you sedetti you speak proper
english like even within communities
that are the same race they have
problems we're going to always have
these problems but then you have to say
what statistical data are you drawing
from that will give you an inference to
say that this country is the most racist
country ever the system is not built for
african americans you say well what
constitution what part of the
constitution that deemed that black
people aren't a part of that document oh
you have none what law specifically is
targeting black
thomas people and you interview thomas
and i watch the interview all the time
and he wrote a book called
discrimination and disparities um i may
have it backwards despairing
discrimination i think that's right over
here discrimination and disparity
discrimination disparities i read the
first couple chapters of that book and i
feel like i'm the smartest man in the
world and but the thing is that thomas
soul talks about this that just because
there's disparities don't mean that
there's discrimination you know so they
don't they they conflate disparities
with racism you know they never talk
about the fact that men represent the
prison system and far beyond what women
are is it is it sexism is the prison
system sexist no it's not it's the
behaviors of men that lead more men to
go to jail uh just because black people
are overrepresented in the criminal
justice system does that mean the
criminal justice system is racist no
one tells sign is that black men commit
54 of the murders in this country
most violent crimes are committed by
black men in america so when you look at
these numbers
you say that can be a correlation to why
there's disparities that doesn't mean
discrimination and racism however they
use those stats to push an agenda
instead of sitting back and saying okay
all of us have worked together to build
this beautiful country no matter who you
are gay straight black white asian
immigrant where you were born here
native american we've all worked
together to a certain degree to get our
country to this point um you can go back
and look in history from the founding
you can go back and look at the
abolitionists and harriet tubman you can
go back and look at the fact that black
people did not have the right to vote
they didn't have a right to do any of
that stuff
how did they get it good white people
decided that it was not right to not
allow black citizens or black people to
not be citizens to have the right to
vote all of these things however you
think that you know so when you look at
it
we've all worked together we've all
fought in these wars to create a better
america and when you see people
deviating from that you realize that
they're
they're probably not truthful and and
you know one of the things you realize
after reading that soul book or any of
his books is that if you don't have
disparities you do have actual
discrimination because disparities it's
like if you had a country that was 80
white and 20 black are you saying that
you want the prison population to be
exactly that to make everybody feel
better or should have something to do
with who's committing the crime i mean
that's so you're right on the facts
stuff but man it's hard to un-brainwash
people have you had some luck in that
department i know you have well i tell
you what god thank god that there are
some people that are waking up and you
know what the way i look at it is that
it's planting seeds so what i do on my
social media and i reach you know
millions of people a month is that i say
you know i'm just planting seeds not
everybody's gonna wake up immediately
not everybody's gonna receive what i
have to say but dude i get so many
messages on a day-to-day basis of people
saying you know what man you woke me up
man thank you man i used to not even
like you that's what they say i used to
hate you man and then i just kept
listening i realized man you telling the
truth and and so there is some some
achievement in pursuing truth because
truth transcends race if somebody's
telling the truth at some point
you're going to hear it and truth will
resonate with you if you're seeking
truth and you're going to say
i may not like the way he dressed i mean
i like the way he said i might like not
like how he said i may not agree with
him religious with his religion but man
i tell you what that's the truth it may
be it may hurt my feelings but it's the
truth and inevitably the people who are
actually seeking truth um they find it
and i've found that a lot more people
are starting to figure out what the
truth is
yeah well listen as long as i've known
you you've been a guy pursuing truth and
i'll tell people a little insider thing
you uh you went on after me at a at a
turning point thing and you turn to me
and you go i'm nervous and i'm like what
you're nervous following me i go up
there i speak calmly forever you go up
there you were you were screaming and
dancing with the crowd and everything
and i was like something is very very
very backwards here but i enjoy being on
the adventure with you man
well i appreciate it dave thank you for
having me on man i mean you're a
tremendous influence and uh i really
appreciate it man the fact that this is
i think our third interview and i feel
like every time we have a conversation
it's always good and productive so i
really thank you and appreciate you for
having me on good seeing you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell